in die Aufnahme, die Aufnahme geschwürfen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja klar, Hauptsache jemand guckt nach mir.
Bevor ich zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerde komme, muss ich noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen.
Falls etwas unklar ist, bitte unterbrechen Sie mich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Nadine Magher.
Magher, ja. Können Sie Ihre Nachname buchstabieren?
M-A-G-E-R
Nadine endet mit N oder N-E?
N-E
Ok, Nadine Magher. Frau Magher, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57.
Sieben, fünfzig. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5.07.69
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Magher?
1,63 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell, Frau Magher?
71 Kilo.
Ich bin ständig ein bisschen abgenommen in letzter Zeit.
Wie viele Kilo haben Sie abgenommen?
Ich habe immer 73 Kilo gewogen, aber jetzt wiege ich nur noch 71 Kilo.
In welchen Zeitraum haben Sie zwei Kilo abgenommen?
Das ging in letzter Zeit ziemlich schnell.
Eine Woche?
Mir geht es halt nicht gut. Ich habe Bauchschmerzen ständig und das Essen schmeckt mir nicht. Deswegen bin ich natürlich auch hier.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie, Frau Magher?
Ich habe so starke Bauchschmerzen.
Vor drei Wochen fing es an, dass es wirklich unangenehm wurde.
Natürlich hat man immer mal Bauchschmerzen.
Aber jetzt wurde das immer schlimmer.
Vor allen Dingen nach dem Essen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich konnte gar nicht mehr essen.
Was auch immer ich gegessen habe, ich hatte Bauchschmerzen.
Dann habe ich versucht, was man unter schonen kostet, dass ich etwas leichtes gekocht habe.
Ich habe kein rohes Gemüse mehr gegessen und kein Kohl und nichts Fettiges.
Aber trotzdem immer diese Schmerzen.
Und schlecht ist es mir. Wahnsinnig schlecht.
Wo genau haben Sie Schmerzen im Bauch? Oberbauch, Unterbauch?
Nein, also oberhalb des Bauchdabels würde ich sagen.
Oberbauch?
Mittagsseite oder rechtsseite?
Nein, eigentlich in der Mitte würde ich sagen.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben? Eche, siehung, brennend, drücken?
Es drückt ganz stark.
Drückt.
Und es ist wirklich sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Heftige Schmerzen. Seit 3 Wochen.
Am Anfang war das nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt wird es immer schlimmer.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten oder nach und nach?
Irgendwann merkt man, dass der Bauch wehtut und dann merkt man, dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Ich denke, das hat langsam angefangen.
Langsam angefangen?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenstikala?
Wobei sehen ist von 1 bis 10, wobei sehen ist unerträglich.
Unerträglich ist es natürlich nicht.
Ich stehe ja noch hier.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich heftig.
Direkt nach dem Essen krümme ich mich wirklich vor Schmerzen.
Nach dem Essen 7 bis 8 ist es bestimmt.
Nach dem Essen 7 bis 8.
Vor dem Essen, wie war das?
Da ist es dann vielleicht nur bei 7.
Strahlen Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nee, das ist nur hier oben im Bauch.
Haben Sie Überkeit?
Ja, mir ist sehr schlecht.
Das sind aber andere Schmerzen.
Manchmal habe ich Sodbrennen.
Das ist natürlich im Hals.
Leider sind sie auch aufgestoßen.
Ja, sonst würde das ja nicht so brennen.
Irgendetwas kommt da wohl.
Was mir Sorgen macht und wo ich mich erschrocken habe,
ich habe gestern gesehen, dass Blut in meinem Stuhlgang war.
Gestern Abend und heute sah das ganz komisch aus.
Der Stuhlgang war ganz dunkel.
Fast schwarz kann man sagen.
Das war jetzt eigentlich auch so ein Grund,
weshalb ich gekommen bin.
Wann haben Sie das erste Mal das T-Stuhl aufgefallen?
Das ist gestern und heute.
Gestern Abend das erste Mal.
Gestern Nachmittag meinte ich, dass ich Blut im Stuhlgang gesehen habe.
Und dann war es eben so schwarz gestern und heute.
Ist das schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie auch Erbrochen?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Aber schlecht ist mir.
Und ich habe natürlich überhaupt keinen Appetit.
Erbrochen? Keiner?
Seit wann haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Bestimmt jetzt drei Wochen.
Ist Ihnen auch gefallen?
Herzrasen, Sturperlen?
Nein, das Herz würde ich sagen, da ist alles normal.
Ich habe nur diese Bauchschmerzen und diese Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Athernot?
Nein, Luft kriege ich schon noch gut.
Das ist kein Problem.
Fühlen Sie sich müde?
Ja, das kann man wohl sagen.
Ich bin total schlapp.
Seit wann?
Das ist jetzt immer schlimmer geworden.
Die ganzen Tage jetzt fühle ich mich auch irgendwie wirklich so ausgebrannt und müde.
Sehen Sie Blass?
Vermutlich schon ein bisschen.
Seit wann?
Dafür, dass der Sommer gerade hinter uns ist, sehe ich schon ein bisschen bleich aus.
Außer diesem Tärstuhl haben Sie auch die Verdauerprobleme? Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Normalerweise habe ich das eigentlich nicht.
Normalerweise? Sie haben nicht.
Leiden Sie unter auch Aufbelegung?
Belegung eigentlich nicht so sehr.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Zum Glück nicht. Vor sechs Jahren hatte ich mal sehr schmerzhaft Nierensteine.
Vor sechs Jahren?
Ja, vor sechs Jahren.
Damals gab es natürlich Probleme mit Wasserlassen.
Das hat sich aber eigentlich gut entwickelt.
Ich habe so eine Harnleiterschiene bekommen.
Und seither habe ich eigentlich keine Beschwerden mehr.
Wie würden Sie behandeln damals?
Ja, wie gesagt mit einer Harnleiterschiene.
Harnleiterschiene, haaa, du blüt, ok.
Sind Sie fiebrig?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber eigentlich fühle ich mich nicht fiebrig, nein.
Sind bei Ihnen vorhin Kranken und OP bekannt?
Ja, wie gesagt, diese Nierensteingeschichte da.
Ich habe einen bisschen hohen Blutdruck und ich habe auch ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen Bluthochdruck und Blut?
Ja, ich nehme, ich bekomme ein Medikament, das ich abends einnehme gegen die erhöhten Blutfettwerte.
Aber ich würde Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie das heißt.
Und gegen den hohen Blutdruck bekomme ich Ramipril.
Wie viele Dosierung, wie viele Mal?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, was da drauf steht. Kann das sein, gibt es 8 Milligramm?
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, da sind 8 Milligramm, weiß gar nicht, was da drauf steht.
Da nehme ich morgens und abends ein.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Krankheit? Bluthochdruck und Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das hat man so vor 9 Jahren festgestellt.
Ist das so?
Ja, das hat man zusammengemerkt. Da bin ich irgendwann mal zu so einem Checkup gewesen.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, also außer dieser Handleiterschiene, die eingeliehen wurde, sonst hatte ich keine Operation.
Keine OP, ok.
Waren Sie in den letzten Seiten beim Hausarzt oder im Krankenhaus?
Ja, beim Hausarzt, wie gesagt, nur eigentlich um die Medikamente verordnet zu bekommen.
Und ja, es ist jetzt schon eine Weile her.
Vor 8 Monaten, also genau Anfang des Jahres, da hatte ich mal in dem linken Bein eine Thrombose.
Dann musste ich ein halbes Jahr lang Strümpfe tragen und habe eine Dose dünner bekommen.
Welche Blutdünner nehmen Sie gerade?
Bitte?
Nein, ich konnte das jetzt absetzen.
Absetzen.
Nach 6 Monaten ist das kontrolliert worden und dann hat man das abgesetzt.
Abgesetzt.
Ok.
Außer diese Medikamente, nehmen Sie andere regelmäßige Medikamente ein?
Ja, wenn ich Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich halt mal Ibuprofen oder so.
Wie viel?
Und dann habe ich, ja, das ist vielleicht auch noch wichtig, ich habe eine Schuppenflechte.
Das habe ich schon über 40 Jahre, also das hatte ich schon als Kind sozusagen.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich nicht mehr so ausgeprägt, aber wenn ich da mal wieder was habe, dann muss ich da so eine Cortisonsalbe nehmen.
Cortisonsalbe, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, nur wenn das sich gerade wieder verschlechtert.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass bei Bedarf nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Wie viele Dosierung?
Und nehmen diese Medikamente nüchtern oder mit Säurehemmer?
Mit Säurehemmer nehme ich den da.
Ich nehme die so mit ein bisschen was zum Essen oder einen Schluck Tee oder so etwas dabei.
Wie viele Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Ich meine das sind 600.
600, ok.
Brauchen Sie?
Wie gesagt, das brauche ich nicht so sehr oft.
Frau Magge?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann?
Ja, ich rauche jetzt schon fast 30 Jahre.
Aber eigentlich nicht viel, also maximal so eineinhalb, ein gutes halbes Päckchen.
Also 15, auf 15 Zigaretten sowas komme ich am Tag.
Täglich.
Und nehmen Sie Alkohol, Soosig?
Abends trinke ich ziemlich regelmäßig ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier.
Zum Essen dazu oder?
Seit wann nehmen Sie täglich ein, zwei Gläser Bier?
Ja, also bestimmt seit ich 30 bin.
Früher habe ich eher mehr getrunken würde ich sagen.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, das nur nicht, nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich habe nur so eine ganz kleine Allergie.
Ich weiß halt, dass ich reagiere auf braunes Pflaster.
Also da nehme ich halt immer, wenn ich irgendwas, eine Kleinigkeit, eine kleine Wunde habe oder so,
nehme ich halt immer weißes Pflaster.
Aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass ich das auch...
Sie reagieren mit einem Hausarztschlag?
Ja, da gibt es halt so rote Pünktchen.
Und wenn das zu lange drauf wäre, würde sich die Haut abziehen praktisch.
Also das macht man halt nicht.
Sie meinen, dass Sie empfindlich gegen Sonne sind?
Nein, nein, nein.
Eigentlich gegen die Sonne, würde ich sagen, bin ich nicht empfindlich.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie vorher Kankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also meine Mutter, die hat halt jetzt im Augenblick gerade ein offenes Bein.
Das ist eine langjährige Geschichte.
Und da nimmt man an, dass sie Durchblutungsstörungen hat.
Aber das ist jetzt gerade erst vor nicht langer Zeit aufgetaucht.
Und da ist sie jetzt noch bei ihrem Arzt in Behandlung.
Sie meinen, das offenes Bein ist eine Wund?
Ja, sie hat da so eine Wunde am Bein und die heilt ganz schlecht.
Sie hat ein Gefäß, ein Problem mit Beinen?
Ja, das vermutet man ja.
Und sie hat keine Alterssuche?
So viel ich weiß, hat sie das nicht, nee.
Und wie ist Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist schon relativ früh gestorben.
Im Rahmen eines Verkehrsunfalls ist er ums Leben gekommen.
Und insofern ist er gar nicht alt genug geworden, um krank zu werden.
Je alt war er?
Er war 58.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Was machen Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Buchhändlerin für einen Beruf.
Buchhändlerin?
Buchhändlerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Das sind nicht meine eigenen Kinder.
Mein Mann hat zwei Kinder mit in die Ehe gebracht.
Ein Pflegekind, Sie meinen das?
Nein, Stiefkinder.
Das sind die Kinder meines Mannes.
Stiefkinder.
Okay.
Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Nee.
Nee, ich war die ganze Zeit hier im Land.
Sehen Sie vollständig Geimpft?
Ja, vollständig.
Ich gehe immer zur Grippeimpfung.
Dieses Jahr habe ich aber noch keine.
Damals gegen Corona habe ich mich natürlich impfen lassen.
Weil ich auch viel Kontakt habe, klar.
Und sonst wüsste ich aber nicht.
Sonst habe ich glaube ich als Kind diese Impfung bekommen.
Sind Sie in Gerade eine Wechseljagd?
Ja, das ist so ziemlich gerade abgeschlossen würde ich sagen.
Seit wann?
Seit einem halben Jahr oder so.
Danke für Ihre Offenheit.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, ich bin jetzt auch ehrlich so ein bisschen erschöpft.
Und der Bauch wagt mir einfach zu schaffen.
Ja, eigentlich wäre es besser, wenn Sie hinlegen müssten.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ganz gut.
Ja, das wäre besser. Ich muss sofort Ihre Vitaparolent überprüfen.
Und eine Venöse-Ursugang einleiten.
Ich denke mal Sie haben eine erniedrige Bluthochdruck.
Ich muss einige körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sofort Ihr Bauch inspirieren und testen.
Und ich muss auch oft kontrollieren mit Rektalenuntersuchungen.
Sogenannte Rektaltrektaluntersuchungen.
Ja, genau. Ich muss auch Ihre Blutergebnisse so schnell einhalten.
So das.
Da haben wir ja ordentlich was vor uns.
Aber muss ich dann jetzt im Krankenhaus bleiben oder kann ich nach den Untersuchungen nach Hause?
Ich denke ja, aber ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Bis jetzt kann ich nicht sicher sagen, wie die Diagnose genau ist.
Wie die Diagnose ist. Okay, dann warten wir ab, was bei den Untersuchungen ist.
Hochwahrscheinlich würden Sie hier bei uns bleiben.
Oder ja, dann muss ich mich halt zu Hause nochmal melden.
Sie warten natürlich auch auf mich.
Ja, okay, gut.
Möchte jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Offensichtlich haben Sie sehr...
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin genommen.
Aufgenommen.
Aufgenommen, Entschuldigung.
Ich würde gerne Sie Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, ja. Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Nadina Mager ist 57 Jahre alt, geboren am 17.07.1969.
1,63 Meter groß, wiegt aktuell 71 Kilogramm.
Sie hat innerhalb von zwei Wochen 2 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Sie stellt sich seit drei Wochen epigastliches Schmerzen ohne Strahlung vor.
Sie stellt sich mit.
Ja, sie stellt sich mit.
Seit drei Wochen bestehender?
Seit drei Wochen bestehender.
Epigastliches Schmerzen, ja.
Ohne Strahlung vor.
Schmerzencharakter ist drückend.
Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzenskala nach dem Essen
bei 7 bis 8 von 10 vor dem Essen bei 7 von 10.
Begleitend klagt sie über Nausea, Emesis, Pirosis, Aufstossung, Inapetens, Müdigkeit.
Und was noch? Ja, okay.
Dann sie hat seit gestern, gestern, der Melena bemerkt, gestern und heute.
Die Frage nach der Tachikardie, die Südnö, die Zürich, Vertigo wurden verneint.
Als Vorerkrankungen und OP gab es die folgende An-Nierenstein-Nefrolithiasis vor 6 Jahren behandelt mit WJ-Katheter.
Arterialhypertonie seit 8 Jahren behandelt mit 8 mg, einmal morgen, einmal abends.
Hyperlipidemie seit 8 Jahren behandelt mit unbekanntem Medikament.
Die Anbetenahme konnte sich nicht ändern.
Vor 8 Monaten hatte sie linken Bein TVT, musste sie Blutverdünnen, sie hat schön abgesetzt.
Bei Bedarf nehmen sie ibuprofen 6 mg und sie hat auch Pesuriasis, sie behandelt mit Cortisonsalbe.
Bei Bedarf nehmen sie Pesuriasis.
Als Nauzunanmese gab sie die folgende Anmessnikotin.
Nauzunanmese hat seit 13 Jahren täglich 15 Zigaretten.
Sie trinkt 1-2 Gläser Bier seit 30 Jahren.
Als Nauzunanmese gab sie eine braune Flasthel-Allergie mit Exanthem.
In Familienanmese gab sie die folgende Anmutter, die leidete an offenes Runde.
Die Mutter leidet an einer offenen Runde.
Sie ist Buchhandlerin, sie ist verheiratet, sie hat keine leiblichen Kinder.
Die Anmutter ist unaufällig, sie ist seit einem halben Jahr in Menopause.
Das war alles.
Was ist denn Ihre Vermutung?
Aufgrund anmessnischen Angaben und geschilderten Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf eine obere Gastrointestinalblutung.
Die Diagnostik ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Die Magenkarzinome, Gastricis, Peptukulcus, Myokardinfarkt.
Obere Bauchschmerzen, ich meine das Inferioremein.
Man kann einfach eine EKG machen.
Auch die Oesophagia-Bolotung, auch die intestinal-bolotung, die ordinal-Bolotung.
Das machen Sie wie diagnostisch mit ihr?
Diagnostisch? Natürlich müssen wir diese Blut abnehmen.
Aber erstmal gucken Sie die Patientin ja an. Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Die körperliche Untersuchung?
Die Algemalsdurchstand ist die Vitalparameter.
Genau, die Vitalparameter. Die Blutdruck, die Herzfrequenz, die Atemfrequenz.
Und was noch kapillärer Durchblutung kann man beurteilen.
Die digitalen Untersuchungen der Muslmanen. Auch die Magen-Sonden.
Aber erstmal, wenn Sie die Patientin angucken, fangen Sie nicht sofort an, deren Schlauche in den Hals zu schieben.
Sie gucken ja die Patientin erstmal an und machen doch eine Auskultation.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie aber nicht gesagt.
Sie meinen Auskultation?
Ja, das wäre doch mal eine Maßnahme, oder?
Ja, genau.
Am Anfang?
Ja.
Dass man guckt, ob sie Atemspannung hat?
Ja, Atemspannung, genau.
Und dass man hört, ob es Darmgäste gibt, was auch immer?
Ja, genau.
Sie haben Vollrecht, weil diese Magenproperationen auch die Brät, Hartbauch verursachen.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht hat sie eine große Perforation.
Das kann auch die...
Ja, gut, könnte auch sein, ja.
Ja, genau.
Ja, also, erstmal gucken Sie und dann machen Sie die körperliche Untersuchung.
Und dann nehmen Sie Blut ab. Und welche Parameter bestimmen Sie beim Blut abnehmen?
Die größte Blutwerte natürlich.
Die größte Parameter, die Blutgerüte, die Blutgruppe, die Leberwerte.
Die Prokastronen können wir beurteilen.
ProBNP.
Aber wer?
ProBrain Natruidik Protein.
Das ist die Überlastung dieser Herzen, die man beurteilen kann.
Um die körperlichen Infanterien auszuschließen, können wir die Tropen verändern.
Natürlich müssen wir die Leberwerte, die Nierenwerte, die Elektrolyten, die Blutgruppe und die Kreuzprobe beurteilen.
Kreuzprobe, falls sie operiert werden muss.
Genau. Falls sie operiert ist, oder sie braucht vielleicht diese Blutspenden.
Transfusionen.
Genau.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt, eine Magenspiegelung.
Ja, nicht direkt. Ich würde gerne sofort rundgemachen.
Damit kann man unter die Diaphram Freiluft beurteilen. Vielleicht sie hat eine Perforation.
Okay. Aber würde man das auch erkennen können im Ultraschall?
Nein, nicht so 100%. Aber mit Ultraschall können wir die Freiflüstigkeit beurteilen.
Das wäre ja auch schon mal erstmal der Anfang.
Sicherlich würde man erstmal Ultraschall machen und dann hinterher unter Umständen röntgen.
Rundgen und natürlich die wichtigste Maßnahme ist die Kastrodendroskopie.
Genau.
So. Und...
Wann brauchen wir Magensonde? Wahrscheinlich. Oder brauchen wir Magensonde, die beurteilen in Deutschland?
Oder EFOP? Man braucht in diesem Falle EFOP.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Also ich denke mal, die Magensonde als...
Aus der Kostik.
Okay. Und dann würde man ja gucken, was im Magen los ist.
Und wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel im Magen eine Blutung hat, dann würde man versuchen da endoskopisch eine Blutstillung zu machen.
Dass man entweder... Ich habe hier stehen Adrenalinlösung, Clip oder Fibrinkleber.
Ja, Fibrinkleber.
Dass man damit die Blutung stillen kann.
Dann haben wir noch eine wichtige Sache.
Ja, wenn die im Magen tatsächlich ein Problem hat.
Wir haben ja eigentlich schon gefragt nach dem Magenschutz für die Schmerzmedikamente.
Was könnte da noch dahinter stecken?
Was meinen Sie das mit der Schmerzmedikament?
HP Nachweis.
Ja, die Patienten müssen mit einem nonsteroiden HP, Helikopterpneum.
Genau, also HP muss noch gecheckt werden.
Ureatentest.
Ureasatentest.
Und wenn die jetzt positiv ist, dann kommt was zum Tragen?
Ja, diese Triple Therapie.
Genau. Und wenn es negativ ist, was hätten wir da für Möglichkeiten?
Wenn es negativ ist, wegen der Schmerzmedikamenten.
Sie meinen das?
Nein. Wie wäre das vorgehen, wenn die jetzt Blut des Ulkos hat und ist aber HP negativ?
Okay, HP negativ. Wir würden einfach Protonpump-Hämmer geben.
Genau.
In der Lebensumstellung. Sie trinken jeden Tag Bier.
Ja, genau. Also Karex und Noxen. Das ist wichtig.
Und Rauchen.
Genau, Protonpumpen, in die Vito. Ja, das sind eigentlich die Sachen.
Ich kann das schon mal sagen. Es war tatsächlich ein Ulkosventrikulier.
Und hier war jetzt noch die Frage, was spricht für die Diagnose Ulkosventrikulier?
Da sind eigentlich drei Punkte angesagt. Das Sodbrennen.
Sodbrennen.
Oberbauchschmerzen und das eben Postbrandial aufgetreten ist.
Das haben Sie im Arztgespräch auch nicht erwähnt.
Genau. Aber ich habe die Schmerzintensität erklärt. Nach dem Essen.
Ja, stimmt. Da haben Sie es gesagt.
Nicht so deutlich.
Dann ist hier noch die Frage, was wäre die Komplikation eines Ulkosventrikulier?
Das haben Sie vorhin schon erwähnt?
Komplikation? Als Komplikation? Das kann... Ja. Musst du Patienten operieren?
Genau. Nämlich, wenn das perforiert.
Perforiert muss Patientin...
Da muss sie natürlich operiert werden. Ja. Okay. Gut.
Ja, wir sind eigentlich schon mittendrin in der Manöverkritik.
Wie immer haben Sie eigentlich schön gefragt.
Es ist nach wie vor... Ein paar Mal haben Sie das Z sehr schön gesprochen.
Aber manchmal ist es so, dass die Wörter unverständlich sind, wenn Sie das Z nicht richtig sagen.
Danke. Darf ich eine Frage stellen? Ja.
Habe ich richtig verstanden. Sie haben schon etwas Nierenstein gesagt.
Schien meint das die Double J?
Harnleiterschiene. Ich weiß nicht, was ein Double J Katheter ist.
Ich meine, das ist sogar noch was anderes.
Aber ich bin kein Urologe. Ah, Double J Katheter.
Scheint das zu sein.
Ich kenne das tatsächlich nur aus der Schilderung.
Aber hier ist es so genannt.
Ich müsste das nochmal nachgucken.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist ein Double J-Ding.
Und Harnleiterschiene. Ja. Vielen Dank.
Wie gesagt, das war alles okay.
Da bin ich jetzt eingestiegen, weil es immer wieder dieselben Fehler sind.
Beim ersten Satz. Sie stellte sich vor, mit oder wegen.
Mit, da können wir den Dativ nehmen.
Bei wegen müssen wir den Genitiv nehmen.
Insofern ist wegen gefährlich, weil der Genitiv schwierig ist.
Und die wenigsten Deutschen können den Genitiv selber.
Also da müsste man sagen, sie stellte sich vor wegen seit zwei Wochen aufgetretener,
postbrandialer, epigastrischer Schmerzen.
Und wenn man das mit sagt, dann kann man sagen,
mit seit zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen aufgetretenen,
progredienten, postbrandialen Schmerzen.
Und dann darf man nicht vergessen, sie stellte sich damit vor.
Und dann ist der Satz erst fertig.
Was mich gewundert hat, sie haben die Patientin gefragt,
ob sie erbrechen musste.
Und sie hat gesagt, zum Glück nicht, ihr ist nur schlecht.
Aber sie haben im Arztarztgespräch Emelis es erwähnt.
Hab ich so gesagt?
Haben Sie gesagt.
Genau.
Warum dachte Sie das?
Ich habe richtig falschen Rahit notisiert. Sie sind richtig.
Ja, und was ich jetzt vielleicht auch nicht schon vor dem ganzen Spektakel erwähnt hätte,
ich hätte jetzt nur gesagt, sie ist 1,63 groß und wiegt 71 Kilo.
Oder vielleicht aktuell 71 Kilo.
Ich hätte das mit dem Gewichtsverlust, hätte ich glaube ich erst später gesagt.
Die Patientin hat Ihnen das ja gleich gesagt.
Deswegen waren Sie wahrscheinlich auf der Spur nach dem Motto, das sage ich auch gleich.
Aber für Ihre Arztkollegin wäre es ja, jetzt muss ich wieder gucken.
Einen Moment.
Nicht Rufinieren. Ach.
Okay, das ist ja interessant.
Ja, als ich im Uni war, werden wir eine Verdacht auf uns,
dass es eine obergasmische Blutung gibt, sollten wir immer diese Sonde schieben.
Ja.
Magensonder.
Ja, direkt.
Jetzt ist ja hier der Kollege Dr. Yusuf, sagt ja, dass die Komplikationsrate zu hoch ist,
dass man das deswegen nicht machen sollte.
Da bin ich jetzt natürlich im Konflikt.
Ich kann immer nur das sagen, was ich hier auf meinen Zetteln stehen habe
und was ich als Fallbeispiel habe.
Und Sie wissen alle, ich bin kein Arzt.
Ja, ich kann das nicht beurteilen und kann auch diese fachspezifischen Sachen
nicht einschätzen.
Hier steht das halt als Mittel der Wahl drin, dass man die ÖGD machen soll.
Möglicherweise ist dann ein bildgebendes Verfahren von außen erst mal sicherer,
dass man tatsächlich die Röntgenaufnahme macht, wie Sie es gesagt haben.
Kann ich jetzt, das muss ich tatsächlich so jetzt im Raum stehen lassen,
dass ich es nicht sicher weiß.
Also hier der Münchner Fall sagt, es ist ein, man sollte die ÖGD machen,
damit man dann auch die Blutstillung machen kann.
Gut, es ist eigentlich alles gekommen.
Ubsoria seit der Kindheit, die Hypertonin, Hypocholestereinämie ist gekommen.
Wo es sprachlich Schwierigkeiten gibt, das ist eigentlich in dem Augenblick,
wo Sie praktisch von Ihrem Fragenkatalog runtergehen und dem Patienten gegenüber
erklären, was Sie jetzt als nächstes machen.
Weil Sie da in so einem Zwiespalt sind, Sie haben da eigentlich die Fachbegriffe
und die können Sie aber beim Patienten natürlich nicht gebrauchen.
Und deswegen müssen Sie das übersetzen und da werden die Sätze auch ein bisschen
schwieriger, verheddern Sie sich ein bisschen leichter.
Da sollten Sie sich vielleicht auch noch so eine kleine Strategie überlegen,
dass Sie sagen, was sage ich denn dem Patienten?
Dass Sie also zunächst mal sagen, der will natürlich wissen,
was ist mit mir los, woher kommen die Schmerzen, was auch immer.
Da sind ja diese Standardformulierungen natürlich erstmal im Augenblick,
habe ich ja nur das, was Sie mir erzählt haben und was ich mit meinen eigenen Augen sehe.
Und wir müssen sie natürlich jetzt noch untersuchen.
Ich werde sie zunächst körperlich untersuchen und dann werden wir Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich fand es jetzt nicht so pfiffig, ihr gleich als erstes zu sagen,
ja und eine rektale Untersuchung müssen wir auch noch machen.
Das kann man vielleicht auch ein bisschen später sagen.
Das ist unangenehm, musst du mich nicht erklären.
Die Patienten erschrecken.
Ja genau, also der Finger.
Also würde ich vielleicht tatsächlich nicht als allererstes sagen,
ich untersuche sie erstmal körperlich und dann gucken wir,
wir nehmen Ihnen Blut ab, dann müssen wir bildgebende Verfahren machen.
Und ja im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung werden wir auch einmal rektal untersuchen,
um zu gucken, ob da irgendwelche Besonderheiten sind.
Aber ja vielleicht ist das so ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Nur Sie sollten sich da tatsächlich vor Formulierungen überlegen,
für alle denkbaren Fälle, dass Sie einfach mal sagen,
ich setze mich jetzt mal hin und denke mal drüber nach,
was sage ich denn jemandem, wo wir ein Röntgenbild mit Kontrastmittel machen müssen.
Oder jemandem, der ins CT muss oder der ins MRT muss.
Oder wo wir sagen, ja was gibt es denn noch?
Der Ultraschall ist ja immer schnell erklärt, weil es auch eine wunderbare Untersuchung ist,
weil sie schmerzarm ist oder schmerzfrei ist.
Das ist ja natürlich immer sehr angenehm.
Aber ja jetzt fällt mir gerade ein so, was ja eher unangenehm ist.
Jemand kommt mit so einem Meningitis-Symptom und Sie müssen dann eine Lumbarfunktion machen.
Das ist natürlich eher nicht so schick, aber auch da sollte man sich überlegen,
was sage ich dem denn?
Also wir müssen da eine Untersuchung machen, die ist schon auch ein bisschen unangenehm,
aber die gibt uns den sicheren Hinweis, was dahinter steckt.
Und dass man das so ein bisschen einleitet.
Ja das ist mir noch aufgefallen beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
dass Sie die Punkte so ein bisschen abgehakt haben, als ob sie schriftlich machen.
Familienanamnese ergab das und das, Noxen-Anamnese ergab das und das.
Eindeutig.
Ja, also bei der Patientin selber haben Sie ja gesagt,
ja ich muss noch nach Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten fragen, wie ist das mit dem Rauchen?
Ja und dann ja wie lange schon?
Und mit dem, diese unvermeidliche Frage nach den Drogen.
Irgendwann würde ich ja so gerne mal einen richtigen Junkie hier reinbringen.
Jemanden, der wirklich viele Jahre lang harte Drogen genommen hat.
Mal gucken, was dann passiert.
Ja, dann haben wir, da haben Sie so ein bisschen mehr moderiert.
Aber im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie ja Familienanamnese.
Die Mutter leidet an Ulcoschoris und man vermutet eine PVK.
Aber zur Familienanamnese gab die Patientin an,
dass der Vater schon vor vielen Jahren im Rahmen eines Verkehrsunfalls verstorben ist.
Die Mutter leidet aktuell an einem Ulcoschoris und man vermutet eine PVK.
Und dann kann man den nächsten Punkt machen, aber dass man das nicht so zack zack zack,
sowie untereinander Stichworte, sondern dass man das mit einem einleitenden Satz irgendwie ein bisschen verbindet,
damit es ein bisschen moderater klingt.
Gut, ansonsten, wie gesagt, wenn es ganz kritisch war, habe ich korrigiert gleich im Gespräch, haben Sie gemerkt.
Damit ich es auch nicht vergesse. Das ist nämlich immer mein Problem.
Ich denke immer, ja, das musst du sagen und dann vergesse ich es hinterher doch zu sagen.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen bin ich gleich eingestiegen und sonst habe ich aber, glaube ich, nichts zu meckern gehabt.
Ja, gut. Alles klar. Dann würde ich sagen, für heute sind wir fertig.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank.
Wir sehen uns sehr gerne am nächsten Dienstag wieder.
Und bis dahin wünsche ich Ihnen allen einen netten Abend. Danke fürs Mitmachen.
Ich finde das immer wieder toll, wie engagiert diese Truppe ist.
Und vielleicht ist mal wieder jemand mutig und hat Lust, dass er mal selber zur Anamnese bereit ist.
Sie wissen, es kann Ihnen nichts passieren. Ich kann Ihnen nichts tun. Ich bin weit weg.
Und auch Dr. Toprak hat es bisher immer überlebt, auch wenn ich manchmal gemein war.
Also nie böse gemeint. Es ist immer so, ich möchte gerne unbedingt, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung bestehen.
Das ist das Ziel unserer Maßnahme hier. Gut. Und ich will natürlich, das ist eigentlich das Fernziel.
Ich will, dass Sie sich irgendwann mal gut mit Ihren Patienten und Patientinnen unterhalten können.
Und mit Ihren Kollegen und Kolleginnen. Das ist eigentlich der Hintergrund von unserer Arbeit hier.
Die Prüfung ist ein Punkt. Aber Sie lernen nicht für die Prüfung. Sie lernen für das, was hinterher kommt.
Die wenigsten von Ihnen verschwinden in irgendeinem Labor und sehen nie wieder einen Patienten.
Oder landen vielleicht in der Wissenschaft. Ja doch, das gibt es schon noch.
Aber in dem Augenblick, wo Sie auf Patienten losgelassen werden und mit Ihrem weißen Kittel und Ihrem Stethoskop um den Hals irgendwo stehen,
da müssen Sie kommunizieren. Und das muss richtig sein. Und darauf kommt es an.
Sie müssen die Leute verstehen und die Leute müssen Sie verstehen. So arbeiten wir.
So viel. Das war das Wort zum Sonntag. Ich wünsche Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende.
Und heute einen erholsamen Abend. Machen Sie es gut. Vielen Dank. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ciao, ciao.